certaines de celles que nous allons vous
présenter au stand ou choquer pourtant
elles sont vraies pourtant elles sont
fréquents nous avons aussi dû utiliser
des objectifs spéciaux qui altèrent la
couleur s'était pendu la seule façon de
réaliser le plus discrètement possible
des séquences qui devait conserver leur
authenticité
nous avons voulu par ces séquences
quelquefois dur exposé un état de fait
la violence phénomène hebdomadaire la
violence renaît chaque samedi soir
parfois elle fait même la une de vos
journaux exutoire désoeuvrement besoin
de s'affirmer
à partir de ces documents nous
essaierons de comprendre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
aller vers un tour au bal au masculin
[Musique]
je
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
jo
aller plus haut
et là vous
cette année
a changé
ne sont pas
alité je ne crois pas la tâche
comment
on est des arabes ne veulent pas nous
les voyous c'est parce que c'est trop
cher c'est trop c'est trop cher non
c'est pas qu'on avait pas eu ces
magouilles étudiants profitent moins
sont là on veut pas donner de l'argent
dans la région et des vols qui sont
elles qui sont guère emballé les
bienvenus
[Musique]
g
800 tr combo guard quoi tous les jours
sa mère
mais pour l'heure c'est sympa les moeurs
at-on bien sa balle et vous avez les
distractions quand même quoi rien ne la
fera faillite
on a quand même des foyers olympia les
ondes jeune homme en a marre en ce
moment il y en a beaucoup ici et les
filles savent à quoi ça va
aj propre est pour rester seul tu le vis
ta vie qu'à moitié
fragile trop belle pour rester seul
je ne conçois pas la vie sans toi
fragile
robert st soir
votre prénom ces collectes vous êtes un
habitué des balles
reflet c'est sympa
qu'est ce qui vous plaît dans l'est
petit confort l'année d'après
c'est vrai quand même c'est l'inversé
selon amd fmi le savon à la butte
avez-vous on s'amuse depuis quelques
jours en mer noire les cherche
ce qu'il vous plaira
kellar 23 23 il ya combien de temps vous
avez horreur
ihome 1,6 en exil
vous arrive de vous avec des gap school
et à mesure tous les servir
qu'est-ce qu'on connaîtra regarde la
caméra vous travaillez un frère qu'est
ce que vous faites comme cela qu'ils ont
ça vous arrive d'être amoureux non non
mais ouais ça m'arrive est amoureux de
l'essence à risque
qu'est ce que vous aimez dans la vie
vous désirez
de quelle sera musée danse est forte
voir vous lisez un peu alan webb les
cowboys les cowboys et les beaucoup de
camarades
oh oui oh là vous êtes très aimé a oui c
est une bague à l'origine aux modèles
pour rester seule dalle est rentré que
[Musique]
j'étais suivi j'ai payé des tribus
maintenant on ne revit des 2 0 très dur
à l'hôpital de christiane et des
retraites tous d'adamov
c'est fini de dames
le jeu
[Musique]
déjà publiés
juste un petit pas
[Musique]
m
les écarts je sais qu'elle a fait ça à
caramel
geste qu'il a fait de moi sorti tous les
jours
money
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
allez dégagez dégagez
j'ai envie que je crois juste reprendre
la mer
[Musique]
vva
sac à main
hôtel 1
[Musique]
en
c'est
[Musique]
le club
ah ah
[Musique]
je
l'apparent qu'est ce qu'ils disent le
design disent rien passé gueule quand
même quand tu rentres tu commences à la
clé bon pourquoi tu rentres acheteurs
nature voir de mal à voir comment si
vous avez des problèmes des liens avec
les gardiens de la paix n'a franchement
j'aime bien emmerdé les flics ça je le
dis j'aime bien garder les fenêtres
oui bonjour
combien museau court
[Applaudissements]
radio j'aimais ça la bagarre
ses dépens je veux savoir ce que vous
pensez des garçons qui se battent dans
les bals de samedi soir ne passe pas
grand chose
rien je n'y vais jamais on va pas juger
quelqu'un sur un moment de sa vie
est ce que vous aimeriez sortir avec ce
genre de garçon n'ont pas dit que ses
dépens oui deux fois
non non pas du tout pour toi
parce que c'est sûrement pas j'ai pas
exactement en fait je suis d'abord
mariée et je suis dans le milieu
intellectuel un peu plus élevé parce que
ce sont des bandes organisées
systématiquement cherche la bagarre ou
est ce que ce sont des gens qui est un
petit peu pris de boisson ses nerfs et
je crois qu'il ya un petit peu les deux
d'une part il démarre la soirée souvent
le samedi soir ils se retrouveront aux
camarades prennent un verre deux verres
se sentent se sentent bien à quoi disons
un petit peu en force de la le départ de
la bande qui décide d'aller passer une
soirée dans un bal dansant bal
quelconque avec l'accord castres par
exemple
[Applaudissements]
pas
la bagarre se déclenche tous les
prétextes sont bons et souvent ils
abordent un client sur le coin du bar
pmu fr
ça commence ça commence toujours par
rapport de trois claques et puis quand
quand il commence à perdre pied si les
gens ici disent où il ya une résistance
réelle
à ce moment là ils s'en prennent aux
matériels quoi s'est passé c'est une
petite part à ces agents de boucliers
alors c'est une chaise et une table
c'est c'est une canette une canette de
bière et on se croit surtout qu'ils ont
besoin de beaucoup de bruit dans une
bagarre s'est il faut qu'ils aient des
verres cassés il faut qu'il y ait
quelque chose se font que ce soit
représentatif croix
du bleu sur les
comment se constitue une bande comment
ce qu elle se forme elle cherche un
quartier général d'abord où il ya un
garçon qui cherchent de coeur soit je
pense que un gars ont essayé de deux
trous vain de trouver un établissement
où il est accueilli parce que souvent
ces gars
ces garçons la croissance ont fait vider
des bars vous avez l'habitude de se
réunir alors là ils prennent pied dans
un établissement souvent un nouvel
établissement à nouveau pour la traction
et viala prend une habitude vient avec
un autre camarade un troisième un
quatrième c'est donc la constitution ce
moment-là de la petite équipe
la petite bande
m
tout est disproportionnée là dedans ça
peut aller très loin dans un
établissement
il y avait eu bagarre générale un des
responsables porte plainte
évidemment il y avait eu dans le monde
dégâts matériels certains y avait un
clientèle était menée l'hôpital en fin
prévue des blessures assez graves et des
des coups de bouteille et ses abus et à
l'ordre ce ce monsieur là quelques jours
après reçoit un coup de téléphone en
on est intimé de te retirer sa plainte
et puis
la refuser bien sûr alors on doit
demander de rappeler chez lui c'est ce
qu'il a fait et puis la famille chez lui
et autour de lui autour de sa maison il
y avait toute une bande qui était là
alors on a rappelé après qu'il ait
appelé lui chez lui et là il a dit que
oui bien sûr parce qu'à ce moment là on
voulait faire là où les faire la peau de
toute sa famille enfin toute l'équipe
était devant toute l'équipe était de
l'or chez lui puis attendez attendez le
le feu vert pour mettre à sac aussi une
petite maison la maison etc
les personnes qui étaient à l'intérieur
et je suis certaine qu'il aurait fait
toute façon
je vois
tant qu'à faire
[Musique]
ja
c'est un procès
et tu dois je le ferai
oui
[Musique]
toutefois comme prévu les voitures
le projet
vous avez des méthodes pour pour lutter
contre ce bengali quand c'est un groupe
par exemple qui arrive
j'ai un groupe de jeunes gens qui sont
toujours par la toux sont à ma
disposition si je les veux assez bien
balancé qui nous permette de d'apaiser
le tout vous mêmes des méthode
astucieuse des projets avec la musique
et j'ai un problème avec la russie leur
fait quand la tension musicale est trop
forte et que je vois que c'est trop
énervant moi même je mets des slows des
tangos des valses cha change ça change
l'ambiance coût total
si jamais vous étiez en difficulté qu
est-ce que vous avez pour vous défendre
empêché de bon air de voeux une prix
qu'un morceau de pioche de manches de
pioche bien évidemment manger et
d'autres bombes lacrymogènes ne vont pas
se faire
ça nous arrive ça nous arrive
m
hadopi 2 j'étais content que tu es là
j'avais porte un caméra pas bander
[Musique]
messieurs quel point les uns pour les
autres
sans tout 95
sans fils
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
responsable des services d'ordre ici à
longjumeau
mais là vous
très souvent 3 qui croient que les
actifs est ce que c'est un discret de
vous demander la rémunération d'un
catcheur par soirée environ 200 jeunes
gens importants
encore
cinq cent mille âmes n'est que si vous
perdez une veste ou un pantalon
personne
vous avez un bras cassé vous pouvez pas
travailler pendant un an
moi ma cerner la seconde
il
[Applaudissements]
de nos jours les catcheurs ne sont plus
aussi employés vont moins de combat
contre x certains catcheurs sont libres
le samedi d'autres le dimanche et
faisant le service d'ordre d'hannibal ça
permet de remplacer avantageusement les
combats
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ouais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dans ma
souvent nous avons qui voyous contre un
seul catcheurs sont même très souvent
armés de bouteilles de
couteau de tout ce qui parle
l'an passé dans les mains et vous
arrivez interface on arrive à faire face
mais quelques voix
notre force physique
capacité de capture ne suffit pas ça se
termine très mal des fois quelquefois ça
se termine très mal nous avons
obligés d'arrêter le bal
d'où une heure du matin gérard tuer tous
les clients français
séjour à l'hôpital
mais j'ai été blessé
en juillet dernier gt1
hospitalisé en état grave alors qu'elle
sortait hier
le grand rocher des projectiles
très souvent les bouteilles
frappé par derrière
[Musique]
poste et je suis même convaincu que
c'est essentiellement dû à la boisson
lorsqu'ils ont dû plusieurs bières vins
même quelquefois 30 dire dans la nuit
c'est fini ils ont tous envie de se
battre sont tous plus forts les uns que
les autres
wang
je pense que l'importance eu des
bagarres dans sa pure malgré eux
servisair
qu'est ce que c'est
[Musique]
l'annulation de
de certains balle un certaine visibilité
c'est qu'ils prennent personne c'est
qu'ils prennent une personne
c'est sur ces rachats mais
bonjour il est plus possible d'organiser
un bal un service d'ordre
il ya deux semaines à jean vilar 10 a eu
des centaines 2020 de casse
jeune jean jacques s emporter
sans plus
les voyous sont emparés du ve
arrondissement et les boissons à leurs
camarades
autour d'eux qu'ils avaient les
spéciales en gémeaux il y avait
énormément de bagarres ou quoi
non il ya quand même énormément moi à
moi j'ai pu grâce à votre présence
p
[Musique]
non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ça m'a marqué
violence
non
[Musique]
le but
je me sens mieux fermer sa gueule j'ai
pas besoin de toi
[Rires]
[Musique]
je me rends compte que j'aime qu'on leur
fait voler
quand est ce qu'il est
[Musique]
non vous n'avez
danton
vaincu par une bouteille c'est beau
[Musique]
oh
toujours w9 est attendu tant attendu qui
les attend leur égard
[Musique]